I need $5,000 to start my business the
question I came in from one of my
YouTube viewers says we who said he
wants to start a graphic design
photography business and he needs $5,000
to launch his business you don't need
$5,000 you don't need any money
what you need is hustle it's never about
how many resources you have it's never
about what university or school you went
to it's not about what country you're
from or what city you live in it's about
how resourceful you are that's what
makes successful entrepreneurs so
successful you look at successful
entrepreneurs you look at how they got
started they're not hugely capitalized
okay they started from nothing and they
found a way to turn nothing into dollars
and keep growing when I started my
business I've been carmical calm I
didn't even have a business model there
was no grain playing I just wanted to
help entrepreneurs I just created a
website I spent $0 I'm creating my
website at the start I had a friend of
mine who knew some graphic design helped
me with my very first layout and I
created the content and learned how to
update a website through Dreamweaver
myself I spent nothing I hate spending
money until I'm making money take the
same approach find a way to get this
thing started you want to do graphic
design and photography you can get
started you don't need anything to get
this started
just start going out and talking to
people when I started doing these
YouTube videos again I didn't want to
spend any money until I had something so
I started off my my digital camera and I
balanced it on my bookshelf and if you
go back and watch the earlier ones it's
wobbly it's out of focus it's not great
you know there's no microphone the
quality was was really poor but I got
started I didn't let not having money
being excuse for me not to do anything
and that's such a limiting belief for so
many entrepreneurs say well I really
want to start a business I really want
to really get this thing going but I
need XYZ before that can happen
none of that is true you don't need 5000
you don't need 10,000 you don't need a
hundred bucks you don't need anything
you just need you and your hustle to
start talking to customers potential
customers understand what they need and
going and start solving problems don't
accept these limiting personal beliefs
that hold you back from being successful
because it's $5,000 now and then as you
grow it's gonna be something else it's
gonna be something else I'm not
successful because this
I'm not accessible because I don't have
that and it's never the case the only
thing holding you back is the story
you're telling yourself and the belief
that you have that it's holding you back
so what I would encourage you to do is a
couple things okay one go out and start
talking to potential customers don't
sell them anything just go out and start
talking to people people who you think
would be ideal clients for you okay so
if you're a photographer are you doing
graphic design you're probably talking
to business owners my go start talking
to them understand what their needs are
see if they can hire you for something
see if you can solve a problem for them
number two I'd go out and start modeling
success look at the people who've had
the most success in your industry and
see how they got started learn how they
got their first customer learn how they
went from nothing to making the first
million dollars and learn from people
who are not even in your industry learn
from people who will products learn from
people who've built software learn from
people who are in fashion look at the
six most successful entrepreneur that
you look up to whoever it is if it's
jay-z if it's Oprah if it's Donald Trump
whoever it is and look at how they got
started because they didn't have a ton
of money launching them they started
from nothing and their stories can both
inspire you to let you know that it's
possible on top of giving you specific
ideas for what you can do to get your
company off the ground I know it can be
really hard when you're first starting
up especially we've never done this
before because nobody has given you the
path and what to do right we don't teach
this stuff in schools
and if nobody in your family has been an
entrepreneur you don't know what the
next step is gonna be and it might make
sense to go get a loan from a bank and
start a business but it's not the path
it's really if you want to have the
success it comes from you really
understanding your customers and being
resourceful to solve their problems at
the beginning find a way to make money
and then once you figure it out that way
even if it's small amount of money you
can invest that back into the company to
go out and try to get bigger clients and
better clients and start repeating
what's working for you try not to spend
money until you're making money and to
do that you have to get on your hustle
and you have to be resourceful belive
thank you guys for watching if you liked
it please give it a thumbs up below I
want to hear from you to leave a comment
underneath tell me what you think leave
a question if you have one for your
business and I'll make a video response
thank you so much and I'll see you soon
you